Thank you, thank you.
Welcome everyone, it's great to be in Berlin,
I like how this powerful the community is.
This is my second year, and it's not just
a pleasure, it's a get honor to be on this
side of the room as a speaker, and, well,
it's amazing.
First of all, let me tell you that I have
not watched inception.
You're thinking, what kind of person has not
watched that movie and why is he using that
title then.
It's just a coincidence, it's just that for
this particular talk I like how JS inception
sounded because this talk is about implementing
things in script engine in I didn't want I
wanted to use this very nice logo‑‑
I wanted to use this very nice low go, that
I wanted to use for a wile that is all CSS,
that I have been tweaking a bit after CSS
conference the other day.
So well, this is all HTML.
But, let me introduce myself, as you know,
I'm Adrian, I'm from Spain, I live in Helsinki.
It's a bit strange, I enjoy the winter, it's
cold.
I love free software and getting into travel.
The first one, free software, Igalia a few
years ago, and I working this still, and hopefully
for years to come, and the second part is
to build machines and Compilers, it's not
the most useful thing for people to like,
it's also a bit of low level for JSConf, no
worries, we're not going to touch almost C
+ + code today.
Yeah, I said travel those‑‑ can be quite
complex.
And lastly the last year we have been collaborating
with Bloomberg to bring ES features into JavaScript
engine, also spider monkey, and also modern
layout to CSS.
And if you have not watched it in CSS Conf,
I would suggest you to look at the grid layout
from Friday, it was very nice, and it was
great to see all the positive responses on
Twitter while the talk was going on.
That's very nice.
So, I'm going to explain what this inception
is about, how do we get the JavaScript into
our engine, V8, and we have time from the
talk, we will keep trying to come up with
a small implementation for feature of ES 6,
try to add it in the 8 and refine it a bit
as long as‑‑ as much as the time allows.
So, there's going to be live coding, I hope
nothing blows, because this is the endt kind
of thing that can go wrong.
Well, to make things even clearer this is
not about trance piling, this is not about
changing JavaScript and trans piling it from
ES 6‑ES 8 or current engine.
It's not about explaining other languages
into JavaScript.
It is not about implementing a JavaScript
engine in JavaScript itself, that can be done,
it's surely a lot of fun, and, it's the kind
of thing you do when you have a lot of time,
but, we oar more interested in getting our
things into actual process, and getting them
in OGS, getting them in places where people
could use them, established process, so, this
is more about adding feature in the JavaScript
engine, trying to touch less of C + + as possible.
Because, the thing is, once the basic built‑‑
machine, the basics are impresented, there's
not much to prevent using the language itself
to implement things.
This is the same that happen was CRC + +,
you is the C Compiler, the C Compiler you
can use it to build a C library or C + + library
and use that in our program, why couldn't
we use JavaScript to impresent parts of JavaScript
or parts of the standard library or at least
as much as we can and then use then in our
own engine? Well, actually we can, and there's
a good number of reasons to do that, I think
we can all agree at JSConf we prefer to use
JavaScript in C + +, it's easier, faster to
develop, we don't have to go with all this
code compiled real test check cycle, so that
gets faster.
It makes us more productive, and very often
the algorithms are more easily understandable
and more maintainable if we just write it
down in JavaScript, and any way there's another
reason we oar not doing it.
I can do it well, I can do it just because.
And this one or two not so obvious reasons,
and one of them is that the modern jus in
time Compilers are really really good at generating
machine code, they're so good that they can't
make faster code than our hand made‑‑
they can make faster code than C + + code.
How is that possible? It's amazing.
The thing is, the Runtime in C + + there's
still going to be a moment in which the JavaScript
code is going to have to call into the C +
+ Runtime
's two worlds, JavaScript world and C + +
world, whatever you use in JavaScript world
you have to convert to C + + values, arrange
the tags, arrange other things, make sure
you call into C + + with proper calling conventions,
this takes time.
This layer of batter in the JavaScript world
and C + + takes time.
If the functions are likely to be well implemented
by the JavaScript engine, we'd rather implement
them in JavaScript, we have all the jumping
from JavaScript to C plus plus and that's
what makes it faster.
Also, engines make very good guesses about
types of things, so you can just‑‑ most
of the time, well, let's just generate perfect
code for integrals, so, yeah, they make very
good code, so there's no reason to not to
say yeah, let's make it in C + + of because
it's faster, it may with slower in C + +.
Then, any way again, just because and it's
fun.
To give you an idea of how much JavaScript
is using engines, this is from yesterday,
I made the numbers yesterday, having checked
with total count of lines of code, there's‑‑
there's most of the JavaScript code is used
in V8.
That's the spider monkey following very JavaScript
code one kilo byte, maybe they're trying to
make one of those one kilo byte JavaScript
contest.
There's a reason for that, the JavaScript
core can revert to an interpreter, so it doesn't
always generate machine code in that case
it's faster to use C + + Runtime that you
have to call in to.
So it's my guess about why JavaScript core
is not using more JavaScript.
Of course, these numbers are not counting
test suites or tools, it's the Runtime or
parts of time in JavaScript.
V8 looks like the perfect match for this kind
of task, that's one of the reasons I use V8
for this demo today.
So, I was saying, implement ES 6 feature,
so, I've been checking, until last week, which
features from ES 6 are not just in V8 that
also they can be implement in the JavaScript,
also that nobody else is really trying to
impresent them, to try to come up with something
new, it's not done by anyone.
And, there's one thing that's not done and
it's a lot of methods from type arrays.
Well, similar to the ones in normal arrays,
but they just work with type arrays, this
kind of Int array, Int 32 array.
That have continue use memory baking, for
example those are used by ASMGS, etc..
So, for today let's implement t Int array‑‑
while it ease easy, if we were patching the
poet type ourselves, there's one slide, small
thing that is not handled by this function,
so let's see a more spec compliant version.
And this is the second argument for each‑‑
we can change the binding of these for call
back that is called for each of the elements,
this is actual lay version that we can go
and implement now.
So, let's do that.
Of‑‑ some music for this.
(Jazz lounge music) so you can see the SRC
inside the 8, there's JavaScript file, there's
one called type array that looks very good.
Will it's go there.
‑‑ let's go there.
Oh, JavaScript, surprise, great, well, several
things that look a bit not so much like JavaScript,
let's just go to the end and patch in our
prototype.
So for each is the function we oar implementing,
Coltbolt, function keyboard, that's important.
Well if this is undefined, then,‑‑ not
this, but this, the argument past is undefined,
then spec says that these arguments should
be implicit this, use of one for this function,
so, it goes that way, let's make a loop.
This is like almost of the loops that go over
arrays.
This is this length.
There.
So, we call the callback, we use this call
function to change the binding of this, and,
we pass data in the position there.
Can this really be this easy.
Let's check it.
Let's build it.
It's of course only generating some stuff,
"building" including the JavaScript into V8,
I'm going to talk in a moment about how the
works‑‑ Ooops, extension internal complylation
error.
That doesn't look for good.
Maybe the JavaScript is not as JavaScriptty
as expected.
Let's look at data view there.
More things here, let's see what it does.
Oh, that's a bit funny.
Oh, maybe‑‑ ...
while we impresenting thing in the Runtime,
maybe, maybe.
Let's see if there's any other ...
function.
Subtype array, maybe we should move our code
here.
Well, install functions, that looks good.
But look at this, it acts as prototype here
and uses global Hlmmm, probably some kind
of module system thing work here, let's try
the global in the front and make maybe it
works.
Again the build phase is fast, let's see if
it compiles this time.
Blah, blah, blah, this time it works.
That's great.
So, amazing.
We have just became V8 hackers, ten minutes,
who wants a full CS degree on a Compilers
master.
Let's just go fetch V8 now of start hacking
V8 JavaScript in there and make the engine
do what you want it to do.
I actually want to show that it works.
Oh rings it sounds a bit strange that duringing
the compilation phase, splits the error, well,
I compile the JavaScript, it actually is,
because, it makes sure that it's not going
to generate errors later at Runtime, and kind
of compile version is included in the V8 library.
Ah, there it is.
Now, let's make an array.
Three elements for example.
And we have from each.
But, hey we have to see if it works, maybe
it doesn't work.
For example we can change one of the elements,
that's usual in semantics, for each function‑‑
do for print.
Hey, it works.
Wow! So we have now V8 works implement in
the JavaScript, it was previewed into machine
code when building, what else can we ask for?
Well, there are a couple of things that we
could improve here.
Let me stop the music.
There.
So, of just a couple of things that we'll
be tempted to do now because there is not
only INT 8 array, Int 32 array, all of those
array that are type arrays, so we would be
tempted to do this.
This would actually work.
We could patch all the prototypes.
A bit of work, we have to duplicate those
lines in there.
But, of course we can do I but these, it's
not necessarily a good idea, remember that
the Compiler doesn't‑‑ is not specialized
in one version of the code for each function,
so ited may fail its guess for the types,
so what we want to do is rather have a copy
of each of the function that is of‑‑
the same code inside, but it's one of the
arrays gets it's own version, when the Compiler
makes an optimized version guessing the types,
it can do a perfect version matching each
one of the types.
And, now, this is a really starting to get
a bit tedious and a bit boring to write all
those.
So fortunately I was saying some strange things
in the JavaScript code that V8 uses, they
have a kind of macro expansion thing that
we can use to, well, to make one implementation
that generates one copy for each of the‑‑
for each of the functions.
For each of the array types.
And this is going to be good because the co‑generator
for each one of the versions once they get
hot and have been used for a while and types
having guessed.
The code will generate the best it can.
Let's see how we can use that.
I'm going to have the same music.
Okay, so let's go back.
Type in array‑‑ type array thereupon,
let's cutlet's go, up, up, up.
Macro type array,ID element size, it looks
like it's generating copy of things, and this
name thing here must be replaced.
For what? Well, for name is 8 array, it can
be in 16 array, let's move our version here.
So based‑‑ let's be nice, so, instead
of Int array, we write name, Hmm ...
is that enough? It seems, so, well, now, it's
version of type array supported by V8, automatically
gets 4 H function had it's prototype, each
one gets it's unique version.
So this should make it that in each one of
the type array classes their prototype has
of reach, that's super.
Let's see if any syntax errors or things.
Ooop, there's an error again.
This was not planned.
The other one was.
So what's the problem here? Maybe it's not‑‑
it's a little bit picky because the macro
extension is not very smart, so times it will
appear in places where one doesn't expect.
So let's see.
Now it seems to work.
Be sure to put colons and semi colons, you
never know how the macro processor is working,
I have not checked the code, it just works,
sometimes makes thing‑‑ things work
again.
Oh, it's a lot of time.
If it sounds like elevator music, it's because
it's almost elevator music.
I have to make sure I have was picking something
with clear rights and those kind of things.
V8 is already revealed, maybe I can just run
the V8.
‑‑ harmony also.
Probably is not ...
that's a bit of a bummer.
If you want to hack in to Compilers get a
fast machine for lots of memory for the linking.
There we go.
I go on harmony this time
we are.
Let's see N 16 array of prototype for each.
Oh, yeah, it's there.
Will it work this time, let's try again with
Int for each.
Let's make another one.
This time Uint 32 array, two elements.
For example, B for each.
Let's try this argument handling works the
second parameter.
To make it even nicer, let's make this an
arrow function.
So let's print these plus X‑‑ let's
process stream for example.
Why not.
Hey, it works, wow! Amazing, and functions
are starting to work.
So cool.
Don't rely on the scoping of arguments on
this so far, but it works, and we got automatically
from a simple‑‑ just one implementation
a copy of the function in each one of the
prototypes of all the type of array classes.
We could make it a bit nicer, we could use
install functions we saw over there, and then
once it's nice enough we could send it for
review and get it to V8.
We're just one step far from being a person
that has a co‑meet in JavaScript engine,
so, I hope after this talk you all go hacking
your laptops to start implementing all those
missing type array methods.
It will get a bit tough with the review process,
but it's going to be nice, and you'll be also
Compiler hackers.
There was those funny thing in the V8 code,
this is not the type array, I can actually
show this one.
This is from normal array‑‑ (Chuckles
...
normal ray...
) we have the code for each're‑‑ we
have this things that are ruersble, to UINT
32, but what is this, JavaScript without types?
It's a Spec function.
Wow! Person sign get the follow‑‑ percent
sign get default receiver.
Those things are there for a reason
are certain things that we should know about
the V8 Runtime and similarly happens to spider
monkey just that it's different.
There's a different approach to certain things
because it's not as fast to do everything
in JavaScript or it's not possible to do all,
all of everything in JavaScript, because just
as I was saying the initiallytion of the Runtime
is done early during the initiallytion of
the JavaScript engine‑‑ so there are
certain features that my not be available.
Also, to impresent certain parts of the JavaScript
specification, we need more information, we
may need to know if a function is anker report
function or if‑‑ an Error function or
amore malfunction, we know if it's an Error
function it will throw and normal one doesn't,
but throwing‑‑ is slow, slower than
just checking a flag, actually the Runtime
the "so‑called" not native functions which
allow the introspect the Runtime and the JavaScript
can manipulate and know more about internals
of the Runtime.
So, of course, this is all implementation
dependent, that's why it's different in V8
and different in spider monkey.
And the parser actually knows about this,
there's a low native syntax flag, we can try
nit the V8 interpreter, there's a lot of functions.
There's some helper functions done in JavaScript,‑‑
wants to check, so these helper functions
are ones that don't have the percent sign,
and the functions correspond, roughly, to
operations as specified in the language specification.
So, for example, in the specification there's
other finishing of what‑‑ is expected
to do and the algorithms in the specification
are written down using the reference those
basic operations that are impresented as helpers
here, so the algorithms that exist in V8,
most of them try to mimic the algorithm if
way it's written in the algorithm specification,
it's easier to do, easier to correspond to
the spec, but it makes it harder time me meant
on JavaScript engines, I would recommend to
check this navetives yes, Runtime yes, macro,
V I, and there's alsod the C + + functionses
like this, get the full receiver, this gets
what would be the "this" target function,
so it checks change and other things that
we have known implicitly when we were doing
the first implementation of forage, you can
check those in Runtime C C and, there should
be Runtime function‑‑ there, Runtime
function is declared with this macro, this
gets scope count, it counts how many scope
there is are.
You actually know‑‑ the engine to go
over those, but with a little time and checking
code examples from the rest of V8 is not that
difficult to get the use the same constructs
as the engine‑‑ so just check the code
and the other GS files and try to follow the
same style and check the specification.
The specification of JavaScript is quite big,
it's something that may get into your way.
It may look like it's difficult to go over
because it's not written in a very accessible
language, looking for examples in the rest
of the JavaScript code is better and of course,
at some point you will need to check the spec
to make sure things work as expected.
About V8 and how it's built, it took a bit.
Actually it picks all the GS code, puts it
in to C + + file as bytes, that is linked
into V8 node nap shot, it's a small utility
that comes with V8 that is built with V8 base
that doesn't include the Runtime, and what
it does is it generates the code for it by
loading those JavaScripts and running them.
And, dumps‑‑ makes a dump of the JavaScript
heap where the code is and variables and in
a V8‑‑ Lib format that is snapshot and‑‑
library, so it's much faster to load, so if
you have‑‑ your stand alone application
that uses V8 you can modify the bootstrap.CC
file and include other scripts of JavaScript
that you have me loaded and precompiled that
are always available as soon as the application
starts.
So, that's something that is quite nice to
have.
So, well, we're running out of time, but I
tell have a couple of remarks: As results
of being here today with me, what I want you
to be aware is that it's not only C + + and
JavaScript engines, it's a way to start hacking
engines speaking‑‑ INT task that we
may know better, like JavaScript, and you
can pick your favorite engine and hack on
them.
Don't be‑‑ don't be squared of the spec.
Ask, go to the ES discuss mailing list, ask
for clarifications, sometimes a spec is not
clear, especially ES 6 parts that are still
changing a bit.
Sometimes you ask for a clarification and
goes, oh, this is not very well specified,
let's give it another try.
So, well, I hope‑‑ I hope you are now
all encouraged to go hack on engines, we need
more people like you to implement this.
So thank you for coming here, and thank you
for becoming hackers (Applause)